look
i call upon every one of you to be
very attentive to everything that the
professionals that the
medical professionals say you just put a
mask on good you have
gloves on great so our healthcare
professionals say
that the vaccines which are now publicly
available
are meant for people of certain
ages you see
people like me we are not yet allowed to
take vaccines you see i am a law-abiding
citizen
and i always listen to what our health
care professionals say
therefore i haven't yet
inoculated myself
but i will surely do that as soon
as it will be permitted
that's one thing second
again professionals say that we
need to have a certain gap between
different
vaccines you take a flu shot then you do
the shout against the covet 19
virus some states should be two weeks
some say it should be
a four-week gap between the
jabs that's another thing for you to
know
actually there's something more
mass inoculation mass vaccination i
think it should be done
and by the way our professionals say the
same
and their foreign colleagues share this
opinion
doctors across the world agree that
one of the ways to overcome this
pandemic
is to inoculate ourselves massively
this is the gateway to
a new future that's how we will get that
hurt immunity
our vaccine is effective and it's safe
so i see no reason why we should be
afraid
of getting a shot let me add something
else to that
you mentioned helping other countries
first and foremost and i've said it
multiple times and i'll say it again i
want everyone to hear me
our primary task is to
give the vaccines to our people here in
russia
there's a number of issues the
components of this vaccine are
safe what we are lacking
is the equipment the hardware to produce
the necessary amount of
vaccines
i think 70 million people already got
flu shots
that's just one example how the whole
country could get vaccinated
and the same should be done to protect
ourselves against the covet 19 pandemic
to produce a vaccine we need equipment
we need facilities
and we will be building up our
capacities as we go
and i believe that all the plans will be
implemented we'll deliver on what we
have
pre-planned for that we'll have millions
of doses
next year now considering the
cooperation with other countries
we need more time to build up the
capacities
to have more equipment in place to
produce vaccines
so nothing really stands in the way of
giving the components and we have enough
of components of this vaccine to produce
them
on site abroad outside of russia
so they will be investing their own
money into expanding
the capacity for the vaccine production
that's what we meant by saying we will
help others but it stands
it doesn't stand in the way of having
vaccination taking place as it
is needed here in russia the quality
will be high
but this will be just growing in numbers
this vaccination
you